when the sirens start to whale at
Lithuanian Xiao Li I airbase the clock
starts ticking NATO command wants
fighter jet pilots here to be able to
take off within 15 minutes captain
giuseppe has been training in a
Eurofighter since the beginning of the
year the Italian troops based here are
on high alert day in day out I like it
we heard he beats a lot very hurtful for
example you're just relaxed and you feel
this alarm goes off and you just have to
run as fast as you can and few minutes
your luck 30,000 feet maybe supersonic
and it's a something that really is
difficult to imagine but it's a emotion
very very very hard since Estonia Latvia
and Lithuania joined the Alliance in
2004 a number of NATO members have been
guarding the airspace over the Baltic
States their own military forces didn't
have the planes to do it for Italian and
for Polish fighter jets have been
sharing the tasks since January
the fighter-bombers intercept
unannounced planes that appear on the
radar since the beginning of the crisis
in Ukraine the airspace over the Baltic
republics has been violated more and
more often by Russian jets incidents
over the Baltic alone it's ironic that
the Polish fighter jets are mixed a
Soviet design now repainted modernized
and beefed up they take off from a
former Soviet air base built in
Lithuania during the Cold War back then
up to 20,000 troops or more was
stationed here potential NATO
adversaries the Baltic republics were
occupied by the Soviet Union for half a
century after Moscow's annexation of
Crimea many Lithuanians are worried they
could be occupied by the Russians I
think a lot of the foreign people's is
afraid of pressure to be a war our
independence is very important to us I
was 18 years old in 1991 when Russian
tanks rolled through the streets and
their soldiers attacked people here back
then I thought how great it would be to
be independent and free now we've
achieved that and can make our own
decisions those European all I know all
culture culture is for me I think I live
I born with that and I I think I hope
that I'm gonna die with that
captain Ava says the Lithuanian have
learned from history she grew up in
shally I located in the north not far
from the border with Latvia it's the
fourth largest city in the country
I could tell you that I was the first
generation of free Lithuanian kid who
started to go to the school and I could
never even imagine that denieth are
gonna be here in my country and gonna
help almost 11 years to secure
lithuanian latin and Estonian airspace
for us it's very important at this
moment we're not alone anymore what
extent would you say our events in
Ukraine are concerned for you personally
for me I'm an officer I'm ready for
everything a confident statement in a
time of great uncertainty Lithuania is
small army views Russian military
maneuvers close to the border with more
distrust than ever the government here
has just decided to reintroduce the
draft 25 years after the dissolution of
the Soviet Union
tensions are once again high in the
Baltic republics but this time they're
members of NATO
you